[Música]
[Aplausos]
vocês receberam alguma coisa do que eu
fiz é minha nave ariel está de olho em
vocês e vejo comigo num possível
agora vou voltar atrás rob né
boa tarde a todos esse é o meu nome
gestual no médio é né último putin minha
família sã são todos os juros o meu pai
e mãe são surdos mesmo mais surdo e eu
sou um sonho até normal o do partido que
nasce e da água tenha vindo com muita
ansiedade mas vocês olham para mim e
hoje minha guia falar um pouco sobre a
surdez dessa palavra amável nada na
consciência qual das duas está a pensar
em me agradava
eu sou uma pessoa tabela qualquer um de
vocês só acorde digital e contra o qual
a diferença é que o destaque que eu já
estou isso é minha língua é na minha
comunicação é enfrenta a vossa assim
começou exatamente igual a qualquer um
de vocês já somos exatamente iguais
imaginem vocês vão na rua
alguma diferença na taça uma diferença
em relação a mim não é soltar e falou
vocês né
esse ano a nova loja só usar aí já tem
diferença na jornada de infância é minha
língua é minha característica minha
identidade é minha língua pode ser a
vossa tamanho
em que temos o silêncio
aqui a voz
são dois pesos pesados
o fluence uma perspectiva geral está
ligado ao silêncio do vermelhinho à
noite a dormir foi chuvosa estão assim a
não tem só a perspectiva da cunha desta
minoria é possível sim é uma sala entre
os que tiram algo está tudo escuro não
há luz qualquer vocês sou viciado não só
em nosso oficiais de ambos
duas palavras diferença elson erros mas
nós somos exatamente iguais
aqui temos a voz é um peso a voz
vocês ouvem uma poesia a voz vem eu
gostava contarmos dói ficando viciados
ouvir a história as pessoas a guichard
você ter resolvido os essa minoria avós
temos voz sai das mãos é e voz que saiu
das mãos
esta voz que é nas mãos também é tão
ligado à guerra os gritos de guerra tal
e qual
é uma voz em alguém vá mans ó acenava
olha por nós não estamos cá nós
existimos
vocês nos mundos nós temos voz é um fã
do jovem estudante sé em 2006 entrou na
primeira vez na universidade assim
superior estava nas aulas as filhas avós
e não queria nada concreto em voz no fmi
mas não passava de comportamento lado
esse grupo combinou e dirigiu-se a
feitoria e tentou falar com o governo do
rio eo corretor e procuramos solução
para esse problema e procuramos através
de uma ponte comunicação e finalmente
conseguimos
nós tínhamos aulas o que o intelectual
gp jesus aulas no branco 11
duradouramente estava a descer em cinco
internos ao gp e as jovens ficaram flu
isso também não gravava depois as
pessoas fazem uma tradução pra lá
escrito é através do comportamento
também havia tutoria sentimos mais tempo
quero é vir mas nas aulas também a
informação escrita e nós conseguimos
ouvir esta voz
meu pai é surdo tem um país ortêncio
filho 21 e os dois estavam a ver um
filme de animação a filha estava
filmando a ouvir o flu e o pai estava
sentada lava firme mas não conseguiu
ouvir esse pai lutou todo o julgamento
do jogador desde que está a lutar porque
tivesse as legendas dos filmes sempre
por cima e final não temos erros agora
os vendas
agora os pais podem o pai e filha pode
finalmente estar a assinar se é muito
simples as crianças ouvintes a este ano
pela primeira vez começaram a prender ao
ser pego nas escolas em diversas escolas
no futuro
xerém teremos médicos que estava já
utilizaremos pessoas psicólogos sabem
jazz usar essa energia vai aumentar e
nós vamos deixar um ser uma menina anda
nós vocês vão à arena
nós somos o mundo estamos num só estamos
unidos precisamos nos unir precisamos
aprender um gesto único em si é verdade
isto é uma prova por um ouvido isto é as
minhas mãos não havia pessoal é escrever
pessoa obrigada
[Aplausos]